With a math background
we can now describe
some of the most widely
used public key algorithms.
The first is RSA.
Named after its inventors.
R backup RSA is
the most widely used public key
algorithm and one of the very first.
RSA supports both public key
encryption and digital signature.
The security strength of RSA is
based on the hypothesis that,
factoring a very large number into
two primes is a very hard problem.
This is, given a large number
it is computationally very hard
to factor it into two primes.
RSA can support variable key lengths.
In practice, most people use
a key length of 1,024 bits,
or 2,048 bits, or even 4,096 bits.
The plaintext length
can also be variable.
In RSA,
every data is treated as an integer
because we can interpret any data with
bits of one and zero as an integer.
And the requirement here is that
the plaintext input has to be smaller in
integer value than the key.
The size of ciphertext is
the same as the key length.
This summarizes the RSA algorithm.
The first step is key generation.
First we select two prime numbers,
p and q.
Say each of them are at
least 512 bits long.
And then we compute p times q.
The result's n.
And while we have p and
q we also compute totient n.
Which is p minus one times q minus one
because both p and q are prime numbers.
Then we select an integer e that
is relatively prime to totient n.
After we have selected e,
we find the multiplicative
inverse of e marked totient n.
Having computed n, e and d,
now we can forget about p and
q and forget about totient n.
The public key is e and n.
The private key, which we have to keep
to ourself and secure it, is d and n.
Now for encryption, suppose Alice
has published her public key.
And Bob wishes to send a message,
M, to Alice.
And he wants only Alice
to be able to read M.
So Bob obtains Alice's public key and
to encrypt message M,
Bob computes M raised to
the power of e (mod n).
For decryption on receipt
of this ciphertext, C,
Alice will use her own private key,
D, and
compute C raised to
the power of d (mod n).
And this would result in
the original plaintext M.
The property of RSA guarantees
that only Alice Can decrypt this
message because only
she has the private key
that's paired with the public key
that was used to encrypt the message.
Again, every user can publish his or
her own public key and
keep his or her own private key
securely to himself or herself.
To encrypt message to a user say, Alice,
Bob would obtain Alice's public key and
compute the ciphertext by raising
the plaintext to the power of e mod n.
To decrypt,
Alice would use her own private key
to raise the ciphertext to
the power of d and then mod n.
What about creating digital signature?
Alice will use her own private key
to raise the message m
to a power of d mod n.
To verify,
Bob would get Alice's public key, raise
the signature to a power of e and mod n,
and this will produce the original
message m and verify the signature.
Again here the property
of RSA guarantees that
Bob will know that the signature
was created by Alice,
because only she has the private key
that is paired with the public key
that Bob was able to use
to verify the signature.